hello I'm gonna stove guy remember it so
you don't have to and welcome to new
segment I like to call what you never
knew this is where I look back at films
you've probably seen a million times but
it's still very likely you've missed one
or two details either in the background
or in the foreground with that said
let's take a look at the 1989 classic
Batman yes it's one of the most
bizarrely awesome and awesomely bizarre
superhero movies ever made but just how
much of it right in front of you did you
miss today we're going to look at the
Easter eggs the tiny touches and the
little winks to the audience that make
us want to watch these movies over and
over again they're not pre-production
post production or anything behind the
scenes for just the kick-ass little
moments you never realized we're making
the movie much more kick-ass than you
thought let's not waste any time let's
jump right into it with the editorial
cartoonist mocks Alexander Knox for his
story about that man but did you ever
notice who that artist was none other
than version of the Batman creator
himself Bob Kane that's right that's
actually called Bob Kane a dick what a
dick that takes balls a lot of people
remember Vicki Vale taking pictures
while Batman saves the day this results
in constant flashes during the fight
sequence but did you notice that Burton
like this effect so much that he
actually uses it again in the opening
fight sequence despite the fact that
there is literally no reason for it
whatsoever
what they step on a strobe light did you
notice that when Batman turns his whole
body turns with him that's because the
way the mask was set up it allowed it so
that he could never turn his head
strangely enough this is something that
would stay in every single Batman film
until the Dark Knight want to be able to
turn
and the filmmakers allowed it for so
long because it allowed Batman to move
totally differently from everybody else
almost giving him a strange unworldly
movement but yeah if you're gonna fight
crime turn your head might be a good
idea - sure me backing out of the
driveway yeah when the film came to VHS
it was actually brightened because too
many people complained it was too hard
to see what was going on because of this
we see a little too much this time
around including the drivers hand on the
steering wheel of what's supposed to be
a self-driving Batmobile you idiot the
art museum was a parody of the
Guggenheim Museum don't believe me it's
only two letters off though I think some
of this artwork might be reprints many
of them have alterations that are
suddenly gone in the next scene I
mustn't compare ourselves to regular
people artists who's obviously obsesses
over the death of his parents but he
finds other ways to keep their spirit
alive including a portrait of his father
hanging in the back and yes it's a
painting of the same actor who played
him later on what the lover is mama
shut up think email arrives in the movie
after taking photos from the corto
Maltese terrific advert doing this stunt
corto Maltese is an actual location in
the DC Universe
apparently carrying quite a gruesome
history and is even the host of one of
lexcorp's labs maybe that's what caused
such a disturbing image I don't know if
it's art I like that bat Belle is great
for holding weapons but not the best as
an actual functioning belt when then a
fish is blowing up the Joker's
headquarters you'll notice it drops just
as he turns you can practically hear the
cartoon sound effect every time it
happens what the hell do you care the
shot is so fucking awesome you probably
never noticed
most of us remember this intro of Billy
Dee Williams as Harvey Dent a man who
would go on to get his face flash with
acid transforming him into a disfigured
Tommy Lee Jones but many don't notice
that this is also hinting that Bruce
Wayne is often away doing his
crime-fighting job clearly this is where
he was sad if he wasn't kicking ass but
hey at least his money is going to a
good cause
do well for now I love that actors
reveal that the Joker has poisoned many
of Gotham's beauty products you'll
notice that the newscasters stop wearing
makeup and hairspray either they're the
Joker's TV finally upgrade to HD Joker
says he needs transportation for two in
ten minutes
Gotham City Cathedral transportation to
ride away sir five minutes
better make it 10 lira not this takes
place in real time 10 minutes a screen
footage goes by before the helicopter
shows up no gonna climb up the stair
seemed to take forever I don't know who
you think you are why the hell did he
take that helicopter anyway when it make
more sense if he just got in the car and
drove away or was a giant flying machine
with his face on it much more
inconspicuous sir what do we do why not
follow the only helicopter in the sky
with the Joker's face on it and see
where it goes ah that would make as much
sense of stopping the Joker during the
parade why didn't they stop the Joker
during the parade he literally announces
to everyone what night he's gonna show
up and what he's going to do okay he
doesn't get the location but I think a
giant parade Flo playing Prince could
probably be spotted pretty fast by the
way if you're wondering where the hell
he got all that money the original cut
had to where it was all counterfeit with
his face right dab in the middle subtly
giving this line all new relevance what
do you want my face on the one dollar
bill hey way to give an idea for Gilly
hundreds vicki vale bitch a lot of
people remember the iconic Batman symbol
it was in the intro of the movie and
even replaced the title for both the
poster on the trailer but would you
believe that's not the symbol that's on
Batman's chest look at those things it
almost looks like it's suffering from
some sort of weird erectile dysfunction
bad STDs him you also noticed that while
the bat suit looks pretty clean and
badass and newer films the original was
a bit more grungy and dirty sometimes
the ears didn't even go all the way up
heck just look at the belt well we cover
that and the number one thing you never
knew about Batman is Bruce Wayne
remembers a young Jack Napier being his
parents killer when he freezes on a
picture of it but if he literally just
moved a few papers to the left he would
have noticed that his mugshot was
staring him right in the face the whole
time yep they called the actor who
played young jack back in just so they
can put in this awesome little detail it
goes by so fast you'd miss it almost as
quickly as Bruce Lee adding to the
tragedy of the events but also the
certainty that Bruce's memory didn't
deceive it well that's good or else this
would have just been confusing
my parents what
mother anymore that you noticed are
there any other little details we're
speaking about well bring them up in the
comments below and keep talking about a
movie that's definitely we're talking
about I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
you